hey there I just saw the movie small
foot I I guess I'm one of the few like
when I saw the trailer for this be here
any sounds by the way my wife's watching
the TV sorry if if you've seen any the
trailers for this a lot of people were
saying like oh it didn't look very good
look very lame I actually thought it
looked kind of funny serving that Hotel
Transylvania vibe and I saw was warbirds
that got me excited cuz I love the movie
storks of course I love the Warner
Brothers cartoons Looney Tunes and
everything and this movie it's it's
complicated uh it's not bad I'll just
say that it's not by any means a bad
movie but it starts out as an
unbelievably run-of-the-mill kid's film
not awful not bad just very
run-of-the-mill it's a musical it's
about these Yeti that live up in the
mountains and they don't know what's
below and they have their funny way of
doing things that involves a lot of
slapstick and maybe half of it is funny
in terms of the slapstick and then in
terms of the humor it's like every ten
jokes they do one will hit but they're
fast that they're not like insultingly
bad there's not like a lot of fart jokes
or anything like that they're just not
super funny that we're I shouldn't say
they're clearly aimed for little kids
and and kids can watch and they can see
how prank colorful it is they can get
into a lot of emotion and stuff how
quick it is the funny faces they make
even the design didn't get they all have
these pear-shaped heads with the same
eyes and I didn't like that but so it's
running this very standard formula where
you think you know who the bad guy is
gonna be you think you know every step
it's gonna take you know so the quirky
outcasts say there's more to what
they're saying and there's a whole world
out there and sure enough one of the
Yeti comes across a small foot which is
this person and travels down journeys
out goes to explore and and finds why it
finds a person if they think FeliCa not
understand each other which I thought
was clever they had to make a connection
even though they can never
ever understand what the other is saying
I thought that what that was really cool
but he brings the person back of the
person is like this TV you know animal
expert that used to be like really you
know used to be this big nature expert
but you know falling on hard time so he
thinks you know getting a Yeti you know
would be a big big deal so he goes with
him into the mountains and the turning
point where it just immediately becomes
more interesting is when he's gonna show
all the Yeti of the small foot he's
gonna show the human he gets up there
goes mm-hmm everybody from the dawn of
time we have wondered and you think you
know where it's gonna go he's gonna go
on and on they're not gonna see the
small foot nobody's gonna believe him
again and it's just gonna be that story
where he has to convince everybody and
nobody believes until the very end at
all we should have believed you and it's
just stick to your guns you know kind of
thing and truth will prevail and stuff
uh but then he takes the human out and
everybody sees him and from there it
gets really really interesting it
suddenly becomes this big story about
sort of what do you put your faith in
when you put your trust in there's kind
of these conspiracies going on even that
is not what it sounds like you know
there is kind of this falsehood that's
being told by the higher-ups but when
they explain why and they show the
backstory and everything the people you
thought were gonna be set up as the bad
guys really aren't and the main
character suddenly has to make a choice
that's very identifiable you know even
though you don't kind of agree with and
it's like well what would you do in that
situation uh and then it kind of gets
into this climax where you know he sort
turns his back on some people but again
you know why and some of them go and
they tried to explore but then that that
can be a bad thing too and it's it's
kind of going for the people or bad
thing you know demand equal bad you know
I I hate those stories two of the
ferngully stories and everything but
then they kind of have fun with that too
and they play around with the idea that
you know not they just see each other as
monsters and you know didn't maybe
there's something can do about me they
can't but there's that difference in the
language where you know they can't you
know totally communicate I mean they can
a little bit but you know if they see
each other they're gonna be afraid and
it it suddenly got really interesting
what's funny about is that at the
halfway point it really is like it
becomes a different movie because the
song stopped a lot of the jokes stop and
suddenly like the characters are really
talking they're not sort of just their
quirks like you know when he comes
across sort of the group of people that
think there's a conspiracy and don't
trust you know the laws and the faith
and stuff like that you can't okay well
he's the big goofy guy oh she's the
weird paranoid well oh that little guy
he's the one that shouts all the wacky
insults and he's really annoying but but
they're not in it too much and even they
sir play actual supporting roles where
they actually do kind of go in and help
and have interesting conversations and
it just suddenly becomes a very
different film so it goes from a
passable kids film to a legit good
family film right at the halfway point
so so it's tricky because I wish it was
like that the whole way through I wished
the fray or at least the first half had
better jokes throughout um a lot of
these jokes and the animation and the
slapstick feels like 10 years old but
like I said one and every ten jokes gets
a laugh and it was legitimately funny
even the slapstick I think when he
finally does go down to the man village
whatever it's called when he finally
goes down the mountain and he kind of
keeps tripping and gets rolled up in the
snow ball in it between his two
mountains like the slapstick is legit
good like classic Wiley coyote Looney
Tunes funny and yeah it's kind of like
what when the Yeti and the human finally
meet each other that's one kind of the
real character development starts to and
I felt that because I'm kind of a funny
story
comes in with her two kids and sits them
down and the songs in this movie are not
that bad some of them are actually very
pretty but then some are priests who
play like the first one just kind of
seems like a knockoff of like the Muppet
movie song you know where they're doing
the big production and everyone's
turning around dancing or the the movie
The Muppets well with Jason Segel you
know that first song you only seem like
a satire that and then there's another
one where they do the human sinks under
pressure singing about his life like
what happened to him
to the song under pressure and his
mother just got up and said you guys
stay here I'm gonna be the movie next
door next movie and came back as it
ended and on the one hand I thought that
was really funny but on the other hand
she missed a legitimate good second half
but I'd be lying if I said I didn't kind
of know where she was coming from
because it really sets itself up like
it's just a kid's film and then suddenly
it gets really interesting combining
elements that we've seen before in a lot
of you know and in monster-human movies
where either humans are bad monsters are
good or monsters are bad and humans are
good and kind of frozen a few twists
with it
even to a point where there's a scene at
the end you know this it's gonna have
some kind of happy ending but at the
same time you don't know how and there's
one scene that legit I won't give it
away but it's a scene that the human has
with the Yeti during the chase scene and
I would just kind of dropped like my jaw
like oh my god when this one scene
happens I think people watching have
seen it you'll know what I'm talking
about and again you know it has to be a
happy ending but it legit surprised me
when the human does something and I
legit but again you see how it works out
but what I like too is that the main
character in this it's it has kind of
all the setup of the liar revealed story
you know the story I hate this story the
one where
one person tells a lie everyone believes
the person so they love him or her and
then suddenly the liars revealed and
everybody hates them and but then he or
she has to go and like rectify
everything if somehow has to make it
better and everybody loves that person
again it has that setup but you know
even kind of that third act where is
somebody has to betray somebody else but
again it's very identifiable you
actually kind of get into the choice
he's making and why he's doing it which
I really like and again it's one of
those situations where you identify
because you're saying well if I was
there what would I do it's tricky and
they make it kind of a time crunch to
where you had to make these decisions
fast I thought was pretty clever and
even kind of the weirder song sequences
there's there's a wrap done in the
second half I think that's like the only
other song done in the second half is
actually done kind of well it is done
very intimidating it doesn't quite feel
it starts off feeling a little phony
like oh my god are we doing this but but
then it kind of turns into this big
threatening production and it's a cool
and the colors are neat and and it seems
very intimidating and it it surprisingly
kind of works so yeah I but the second
half for this I don't think it's great I
don't think it's phenomenal or anything
but but it's a legit good family film
and maybe I don't know maybe what kind
of makes me appreciate this I can help
even more is because I so thought it was
gonna go the direction that the first
half is setting up
because it was so playing it by the
numbers and then suddenly the second
half gets really interesting and I wish
the first half was either as interesting
or was a lot funnier but with what we
got I think this is pretty good so if
you're going into this if you have kids
take the kids to see then they'll love
it that they'll enjoy the slapstick in
the comedy at first half and they'll be
invested in the second I saw kids
running out laughing and then quoting
lines and
and they're really excited the chasey
and their reenacting it so kids I think
will love this for the adults give it a
chance
don't be like that lady that went into
the next theater um unless it's like a
really good movie next door I don't know
you pay for a movie see the movie but
yeah give it a shot at the halfway point
it gets legit interesting and it's like
I said it combines a lot of familiar
elements that you've seen kind of from
lesser family fear or even lesser I
shouldn't say lesser it just kind of
these cliches have been done alive but
they take these elements and kind of
pick different parts of it and put it
together and make something kind of new
okay kind of interesting or new enough I
should say it was enough to keep my
interest and enough for me to say okay
I'm invested and I want to know what
choices are gonna make and wanna know
how they're gonna get out of it and I
want to know how they're gonna get their
happy ending because everything they're
setting up it's like my okay it's it's
gonna be difficult to you know wrap this
all up and and it's nice for a kid's
film too because it is very
anti-authority which I kind of like but
in a smart way it's not like stick it to
the man because the man is a man a
person which I like and they make it
look like he's gonna be a villain but
they don't they actually make this a
legit person you understand where he's
coming from and I think that's important
because a lot of anti-authority films
especially in family films just make
them look bad there's one bad guy or a
lot of bad guys and there really are no
villains in this that's what I was
really really happy to see that at the
end of the day it's like okay there was
no nobody has dropped off a cliff and
his reign of terror is over anything
like that it is legitimately
identifiable and understandable where
these characters are coming from and why
they're doing what they're doing and
they come to a reasonable outcome at the
end as well so I'm really happy about
that so I would say this is actually a
very good film for kids even though it
starts off as a very standard film for
kids if someone gets really good for
kids and it turns into
decent-enough family film I think so if
you're an adult and you're wondering
whether or not to see that I would say
give it a chance just with the you know
knowledge that it's gonna start off
clunky alright and standard it's gonna
start off very standard and it's gonna
get better it's gonna get stronger as
you watch it so yeah that's my thoughts
on that go tell me what you think I'm
actually really curious if people like
this film or if they see it as too corny
and lame and sporadic but by the end of
house really glad I saw it I thought it
turned out pretty good so that's about
it I'll see you next time take care
you